yeah it's a complete closure of us-95  southbound at ann road so anybody up in  the far northwest and you use the 95 to  get into town you cannot do that this  crash happened at 12 30 this morning  nevada highway patrol says it was a  single vehicle fatal motorcycle crash  here's a live look at the scene you've  got the investigators parked here we've  had people walking along the roadway  trying to get pieces for their  investigation southbound drivers you  have to get off it and road you don't  have a choice however the detour is not  super complicated you can go east over  to jones down to craig west over to  durango down to craig that will get you  back onto the 95 southbound